we've talked about the scam grifting
around the virus and we previously
mentioned this super-rich televangelist
scammer Kenneth Copeland Copeland's 83
years old he's built a net worth of
seven hundred and sixty million dollars
if you can believe it on the backs of
scamming poor Christians out of money
now poor might be economically poor or
cognitively poor or I don't you know you
you can interpret that however however
you want but it has afforded Kenneth
Copeland private jets and houses and
cars and the whole thing for this guy we
have a new clip of him finishing
coronavirus by commanding God to destroy
it so we're going to look at the clip if
you're listening today on the radio or
to the audio podcast I encourage you go
and find the YouTube clip for this story
because the visual is really important
you're gonna see Copeland behaving like
a lunatic but he also has another guy
next to him it's almost like a hype man
at a lectern next to him sort of
repeating some of the things Copeland
says egging on the insanity it's really
really crazy and remember for Kenneth
Copeland to do this stuff you've got to
keep tithing you have to keep sending
him ten percent of your income take a
look at this thank you Jesus the prophet
of God I execute judgment on you covet
night goes on judgment on you Satan you
destroy you kill you
a vaccination of comedian yes it
actually makes me physically
uncomfortable to watch this stuff it's
not like a cringe reaction it's almost
like a GI distress like I start to get
nauseous watching this stuff and of
course all of the normal contradictions
Satan brought the virus so he commands
God to destroy it why didn't God merely
prevent the virus in the first place
he's asking for a vaccine well who makes
the vaccine is it God why would God
allow the virus and then make a vaccine
why not just prevent the virus to begin
with seems simpler to me Oh Oh David
come on God works in mysterious ways and
you've got to keep sending kind of
Copland money let's watch a little bit
more of this if we can tolerate it from
your place of authority destroyer you
come down like God commanded you when he
put his foot on your head in the garden
what really gets me about this is that
in this context where this guy has like
a congregation I guess you'd call it or
maybe it's a ministry I don't know in
this context this guy's wearing a suit
and there's cameras in the room and he
says send me money for these rants
there's no practical difference in terms
of what this guy is saying between
Kenneth Copeland wearing a suit in front
of cameras and you know a guy ranting in
the subway who should be committed to a
psych ward and I'm not saying that
pejoratively about the guy in the subway
we're talking about mental illness here
right the difference is one guy's
wearing a suit the other guy's not one
guy has cameras filming him the other
one does not one guy has marketing
behind him saying you should be sending
in money for this stuff the other guy
does not that's the only material
difference here now some people would
disagree with me and would say David
Kenneth Copeland's not crazy he's just
evil he
knows that this stuff is lies he's doing
it not because he believes it and he's
crazy he's doing it just to steal
people's money I don't disagree the
point is the rhetoric is the type of
stuff that paranoid schizophrenic in
psych wards would normally say he may
well be acting just to get people's
money no doubt about it but the only
real difference is the marketing the PR
and Kenneth Copeland has better lighting
than the guy ranting on the street
corner
if these faith healers really had the
powers go to a hospital and heal someone
seriously ill from kovat 19 right go and
put your hands and and say your prayers
for someone on a ventilator and heal
them it would be immoral not to if this
nonsense actually worked then we'd have
something to talk about really sad
that old folks keep getting scammed they
keep going out there getting haircuts
they're hanging out at malls they're
ignoring social distancing rules and
part of it is they can send this guy
cash to pray away the virus part of it
is you know watching Fox News and the
rhetoric there it's very very ugly stuff
and it's not a joke it's not a joke
people are actually dying as a result of
this one of our sponsors Nord VPN is
giving you 70% off a three year plan
which comes out to just a little over
three bucks a month and you'll get an
extra month free when you go to Nord VPN
comm slash David Pakman or just go to
their site and use the coupon code David
Pakman it's 20/20 there is really no
reason not to be using a VPN not using a
VPN means you are not taking your
internet safety seriously I use Nord VPN
almost any time I'm using the Internet
it hides your IP address when you're
browsing online keeps you safe from
hackers keeps websites from tracking
your browsing activity many advantages
and Nord VPN is the most trusted VPN in
the game they don't log your internet
activity like many other VPNs do their
servers are super fast and you can even
use it on your phone Nord VPN is giving
you 70% off a three-year plan that's
just over three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
North Vee PN dot-com slash David Pakman
I've put a link right underneath the
video or just go to their website and
use the coupon code david pakman